this is a mixture of white clay mixed
with tamarind
thousands in southern madagascar are so
desperately hungry
they've turned to dirt to fill their
stomachs the people
are eating whatever they can find
between cactus mixed with mud
roots whatever they can find leaves
seeds whatever is available
their hunger is born of years of drought
now
exacerbated by a recession from covert
19. seasonal employment
has dried up we feel like vomiting all
the time because we really have nothing
to put in our mouths
now water becomes our meal
this centre in baraketa focuses on
severely malnourished children
they see 50 each week and 100 more
adults
my children didn't eat for three days
and then died because
i their mother did not manage to feed
them
i'm sure it was the farming that killed
them it's not something else
it's not disease but famine
the un is already providing food for
half a million here
it says it needs to nearly double that
by june
half a world away at un headquarters in
geneva
representatives with the world food
programme pitched for money
35 million dollars for emergency food
and malnutrition
programs so more madagascarians don't
starve
what we are saying here is that the
situation we are facing in southern
madagascar
is not normal it's very different to any
normal year of crisis
and that we really need to act
immediately 300 000 people
need at the moment safe lighting support
their projections say 1.35 million
people
will soon struggle to find their next
meal that's a third
of the regional population charlotte
ballas al jazeera